Okay, this time I'm gonna overline a little bit.
Also, I've heard people say that it doesn't.
It doesn't peel that easily.
You need to let. It says on the thing,
let it dry. So even though if it feels like, oh,
I could probably peel it off,
you're peeling it off too early.
It's a stain. Leave it on a little while.
Let it even when it's dry,
let it sit.
Cause I truly believe that's where the staining magic happens.
You know, I feel like if you get the right color,
it helps add a little fullness to your lips
without having to get injections.
It just gives, like,
a little bit of color to that little line that all the girls overline,
but it gives it in a more natural way.
Okay, 10 to 15 minutes.
If you want it to stain, let it sit in 12 minutes.
You let it sit long enough,
it comes off perfectly easy.
Okay, well,
that's all I have. Let's do this one.
It's very cosmic.
Oh, it's cute.
It does stay on even with a gloss over top?
Yep. If I say, oh,
I don't like that gloss anymore,
I still have the stain. I mean,
you can't scrub hard. But yeah,
it stays even if I put gloss over top.